do you think about your own mortality
look i'm uh i'm a
devout christian and uh so i'm a big
believer that there's
uh this is just a
transition and
but
don't spend a lot of time thinking about
that i'm
i am
somebody good better and different that
try as much as possible to leave the
present and that's what i do
and try to make the present better on
this on this place here on earth
absolutely and that some of these
technologies some of these ideas are
kind of
a different kind of immortality as well
because they they propagate through time
and have impact on people
in the best possible way so technology
can be scary technology can be
destructive but it seems like in the end
it can be
it can do a lot of good more people
there's more good than bad
what do you think is the meaning of this
whole thing i asked you about aliens
observing us
what what's the meaning of life
cristiano
what's the meaning of life
easy questions that's not an easy
question at all
i think that's uh that's the question at
least for me you have to answer
individually uh
but uh i do believe we're all here for
purpose uh you know i
i
you know in my prayers i always ask that
you know i'm i stay on track to whatever
my purpose is
but i do believe we're here for purpose
and we need to do the best we can during
the time we have on this earth
so that means
create beautiful things for you
what about love
what's the role of love in the human
condition
love's very important and uh it's an
essential part of
being human it comes in the package
and uh i think if look at the situation
what's happening right now i think uh
you look at the situation with some of
the underprivileged uh communities look
at the homeless situation i think we all
need more love yeah and i think people
that build incredible technology
sometimes forget the love part like
those are all it's all integrated
there's no
thinking about humanity
is really important when you build tools
that empower that humanity because
there's i think i at least i personally
believe we're all capable of both evil
and good
and we have to build technology build
societies build governments build
communities that
um inspire us to
to connect with the good part within all
of us i'm a big believer that technology
is at the end the force for good and if
just look if you just look you know not
trying to
move away from a deep discussion to a
more uh specific technical one but if we
started the conversation talking about
smartphones
and uh smartphones really the first time
that you could say that everybody in the
world was able to connect to the
internet and connect to each other and i
think what
that empowerment that that provided it's
an incredible force for good
well
the company you lead the the technology
you've created one of them that i'm
especially excited about which is
snapdragon the whole line of processors
there currently i would say at about
10 billion transistors
if you think about the human brain it's
about 100 billion neurons
so i think uh 11 samsung galaxy 22s s22s
are already smarter than me and that's
being nice
uh to me
i'm really honored that you spent your
extremely valuable time with me uh even
though you said play is the favorite
player um beyond all of that uh i think
you're an incredible person an
incredible leader and you lead an
incredible engineering company so thank
you for doing that oh thank you so much
thanks for the kind words really a
pleasure having this conversation i
really had a lot of fun doing it and
thank you for having me in the podcast
you